aucune loi pour encadrer les violences
conjugales
voici la réalité pour les femmes battues
dans les années 70 à cette époque les
sujet est encore tabou dans la société
française et frappé sa femme est encore
pour certains considéré comme un acte
banal et la tradition populaire sont
distraits qui dit batta femmes tous les
jours
si tu ne sais pas pourquoi elle elle le
sait pour sensibiliser l'opinion
publique
les associations de femmes battues se
met en place et encourage les victimes a
témoigné dans les médias en 1978 après
plusieurs années de lutte
l'association sos pam alternative
obtient enfin des subventions de l'état
pour la création du premier refuge à
clichy dans le nord de paris
il fonctionne comme un service d'urgence
et peut éviter que des situations
intolérables se termine en tragique fait
divers blessé physiquement moralement
par des violences répétées qui mettent
leur vie en danger
elle trouve là une sécurité après cette
première avancée symbolique il faudra
encore attendre onze ans en 1989 pour
que les violences conjugales devienne
l'une des priorités majeures du
gouvernement les ministères des droits
de la femme lance aujourd'hui une
campagne pour alerter l'opinion sur ces
violences conjugales l'idée c'est à
terme de faire voter une loi sur ce
sujet trois ans plus tard en 1992 le
gouvernement annonçait la mise en place
du premier numéro national dédié aux
victimes
une initiative de la secrétaire d'état
aux droits de la femme véronique nyrs il
dénonçant la violence conjugale comme
ina
cette table c'est pour cela que si votre
compagnon ou votre mari vous bonne 10
ont refusé la violence et pour savoir à
qui s'adresser
nous avons créé cette permanence
téléphonique national deux ans plus tard
en 1994 les violences conjugales sont
enfin reconnus comme un délit en france
seize ans après la création du premier
refuge pour femmes battues
la législation continuera ensuite de se
renforcer en 2009 le gouvernement
reconnaissait même officiellement les
violences conjugales comme une grande
cause nationale
une femme meurt tous les deux jours sous
les coups de son conjoint en france
françois fillon parle des cats ont un
nouveau délit de violences
psychologiques au sein du couple sera
créé le premier ministre a aussi annoncé
que des bracelets électroniques seront
testés pour éloigner les maris ou les
concubin violent
malgré ses 25 années d'avancé
législatives les violences conjugales
reste toujours un fléau difficile à
éradiquer
selon les derniers chiffres officiels en
2010 8 121 une femme mourait encore sous
les coups de leur conjoint ou ex
conjoint
[Musique]